[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ERS just released a new teaser for the
upcoming Godzilla and Kong movie the one
that will be released next year and this
reveal will blow everyone's Minds like
literally mind blasting as the great
Russell Peters once said so let's get to
it the new movie will just be truly epic
that I know I hope and I pray the
official title and the first teaser
trailer to the sequel of 2021's Godzilla
vs Kong has just been revealed providing
fans a glimpse of the upcoming legendary
feature the sequel is named Godzilla and
Kong the new Empire according to a
message from the Godzilla versus gong
Twitter account which also contains a
teaser trailer for the next movie The
teaser begins with a behemoth sized ape
titan Seated on a throne room surrounded
by Bones the same throne room that gong
sat upon in Godzilla vs gong then the
scene pans out to reveal Godzilla and
Kong's skulls each gleaming with their
unique colors one blue and the other
orange and then another scene where we
see a close-up of the ape titan and he
seems to have a very Sinister look
as the movie synopsis reads the latest
entry follows up the explosive showdown
of Godzilla vs gong with an all-new
cinematic Adventure pitching the
almighty Kong and the Fearsome Godzilla
against a colossal undiscovered threat
hidden within our world challenging
their very existence and also our own
the Epic new movie will delve deeper
into the histories of these Titans their
Origins and the mysteries of Skull
Island and Beyond even the hollow Earth
all the while uncovering the Mythic
battle that helped Forge these
extraordinary beings and forever linked
them to humanity so who is the new
villain that is what we want to know
well that's not Destroyer that is
evidently clear obviously
is it a titanus Kong or a new monster
well by the looks of it it is obvious
that it isn't any of the Titans that
attacked the planet during the king of
the Masters the only mammalian Tyrant
there was Behemoth and that isn't really
him that isn't him it just looked like
Kong but appears to be Slimmer and
lankier in physique when we first read
the synopsis we knew for sure that this
won't be an enemy that we have seen and
that is what led many fans to speculate
that one of the old Touhou kaijus like
space Godzilla or even destroya to be
the main threat but this creature has
fur and it isn't King Caesar either
there are two theories that I will put
out the first one might be that this
will be a hollow Earth kind of Scar
villain to Mufasa's Lion King a rogue
Kong specimen that was exiled by the
other cons and is extremely old at this
timeline but full of Vengeance so he
would be bigger and angrier than either
of the Apex tyrants another theory is
that he is a another Super species
closely related to that of Kong but as
Kong is more of a gorilla this one would
be more orangutan-like
its design is truly magnificent even
though it's mostly just silhouette from
close by we see it covered in fur but
this fur isn't grayish black as we see
in Kong no this one has a reddish orange
tint it has two very long arms longer
than what gong has so this confirms my
second theory that this might be a new
super species its hands the hands not
the arms they are black in color and its
legs are only slightly seen curl up in a
squatting position or maybe it's a yoga
position and I don't know I'm not a
sitting position expert anyway when the
scene pans out its eyes are seen glowing
with a white color now this looks
menacing because at the same time we
hear its role and it sounds nothing like
Kongs it has a deeper growl that seems
to be filled with vengeance and anger so
in the next scene we see it close up it
has a red wall paint on its face and yes
the fur is reddish orange in color but
what is most remarkable is its glow eyes
which we see now as being bluish in a
way similar to that of Godzilla's and
now the question arises will it have
similar powers
and also will the story be set in the
past or the present well if you think
about it this isn't really a trick
question the name of the movie itself
says the new Empire if it was Godzilla
Millionaire's BC Theory then wouldn't it
be called the old Empire my best guess
would be that this villain will be a
survivor of the ancient Titan war that
enveloped the entire Hollow Earth in the
past and he and his kind are just here
alone would either be a Kong or a
subspecies that found itself in the
crossfire between the Godzilla vs com
conflict he might also be the cause of
the Great War itself but that is another
theory again anyway there will
definitely be sequences in the movie
that depicts the massive conflict and
then the rest of the storyline will be
set in the present day
now the next question is will Godzilla
and Kong team up again for this battle
hell yeah otherwise why would they piece
out each other in the last movie again
as the movie synopsis reads pitting the
almighty Kong and the Fearsome Godzilla
against a colossal undiscovered threat
etc etc this new enemy would be like
nothing the planet has ever seen before
all seen again since the ancient war by
the looks of it the ape title might have
both the intelligence and the Tactical
battle abilities of Kong and also the
size as well as the atomic power of
Godzilla and just as in the case of
Mechagodzilla it would take both of them
in a team effort to win this fight but
it could also be the death of either one
of the Titans in the end
so there is another thing we have to
discuss so when we see the scene pans
out and we see the glowing eyes of the
enemy Titan and at the same time we see
all over the throne room that there were
bones and skulls of many other different
Titan super species this means only one
thing that there is gonna be War there
are gonna be a lot of Titan battles and
deaths in this new movie it will be kind
of like a final walls kind of vibe and
that is what I take out of it out of
that gruesome teaser so in the end of
that scene again we saw the skulls of
both Godzilla and gong so this will
foreshadow the death of either one or
both of them at the hands of this new
one but as of now let's just hope for
the best and maybe the live action
series Godzilla and the Titans might
feature clips and scenes that will be
tied in with the story of this new
Empire
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe and most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam